battles leave scores
some you can't see I will never let my
friends get hurt again Duvall Acron I'm
afraid it's changing him what if there
are secrets we can learn from it that'll
help us destroy the sin
Ezra the secrets in that being almost
destroyed you know I'm judoka dad's the
sky strike Academy who wish to defect to
the rebels this is time s s25 you can
call me wedge
welcome to the rebellion so can't
believe we're here to break this guy out
of prison
my friends my friends I give to you Greg
flem station if we could steal a
squadrons worth they would be key to
building a strike fleet let's go get him
everybody ready yep let's go one last
glorious day and the Grand Army of the
Republic
flying stormtroopers worse Mandalorians
who serve the Empire
you haven't forgotten our ways that has
earned my respect
so what's in it for you too which is
untold that sort of thing so we'll split
the treasure split the treasure that's a
classic governor price these rebels have
proven particularly stubborn how do you
intend to solve this problem I need
someone who sees a bigger picture the
Empire is getting better at anticipating
our moves I underestimated the commander
previous attacks were clumsy but this
one was sweet precise
to defeat an enemy you must know them
not simply their battle tactics but the
history philosophy Oh Grand Admiral
Thrawn karabast
embrace your destiny
yet I am sitting the light of the God
I'm the one in the middle the ban do
once a secret is no no your anger gives
you strength
I will call the rebels apart piece by
piece
I must become more powerful they'll be
the architects of their own destruction
that's what put away before it's too
late the key destroy
hey youtubers is Charlie so Star Wars
Celebration still going on they drop
Grand Admiral Thrawn he is officially
canon to the new Star Wars universe so
let's break it down so if you guys don't
know why everyone's freaking out about
this new blue character Grand Admiral
Thrawn he was huge in the EU the Thrawn
Trilogy was kind of like the first big
saga of books in the 90s that was part
of the expanded universe it was the
beginning of this big Renaissance for
Star Wars at Lucasfilm in the 90s
because between Return of the Jedi in
the prequels there weren't any new
movies so there was like a period of
more than 15 years with just no new Star
Wars so when the Thrawn Trilogy came out
it told the story of Luke Skywalker
after Return of the Jedi so it was like
moving the story forward in a really
interesting way so it deepened the
mythology of the force introduced a
whole bunch of new characters you meet
this new Jedi Master you learn more
about the Emperor like the the film's
didn't really spell out a lot about
Emperor Palpatine at the time so it was
just like this broadening of the Star
Wars universe but the way they
introduced Grand Admiral Thrawn was even
though he was kind of like a combination
of Darth Vader and Grand Moff Tarkin
he wasn't force sensitive but he was
like the Emperor's secret weapon that
nobody knew about it was just this
military genius in the fun way that they
explained him because it's like you know
where did he come from if he was so
awesome how come he wasn't in the
original movies how come he wasn't
helping the Empire they might change it
a little bit for the TV show but the way
they explain it is that the Emperor was
super racist super sexist so that was
just like a clever way for them to
explain why you only saw white human men
leading on the bridge of all these Star
Destroyers like how come all these big
badasses in the Imperial fleet are all
British and all white men so I don't
know how they're gonna change that
explanation but Grand Admiral Thrawn
leads the seventh fleet so he has like
this giant fleet of stardestroyers he's
like the secret weapon that you didn't
know about like surprise so a
lot of this trailer is just teeing him
up as the new big bad we have grand moff
tarkin of course Darth Vader's still out
there somewhere but Grand Admiral Thrawn
will be like the big bad of Star Wars
rebels they even played this recorded
message from Timothy Zahn he's the
author of the Thrawn Trilogy so they
brought him onto console to help them
bring Grand Admiral Thrawn into the Star
Wars universe and they did air the first
episode at Star Wars Celebration and
it's a bit of a slow Burtt like they
don't go too crazy
that they mostly just introduce his
character give you an idea for how much
of a badass he is but it just lays a lot
of groundwork so like you see Ezra here
with a different haircut so you
definitely know some has gone down
because he's been working with Darth
Maul in another deep cut from the
expanded universe so if you never read
the expanded universe novels
they also broaden the mythology of the
force in a real interesting way
just saying that it's not binary like
it's not just light and dark side the
force is a much broader concept so you
have this new character here the Bendu
character played by Tom Baker from
Doctor Who Fame so just another David
Tennant Doctor Who deep cut David
Tennant was a huge character during the
Clone Wars and if you have never watched
Doctor Who don't worry you don't have to
watch Doctor Who but the actor that's
voicing this character this Bendu
character which I'll explain in a second
was kind of like the obi-wan Kenobi of
Doctor Who way way back in the day but
the Ben do what's the Ben do so he
basically says that he's in the middle
you know light side dark side I'm the
one that's in the middle the term Ben do
is actually taken from George Lucas's
original name for the Jedi originally he
called them the Ben do Ben do monks so
it's a huge deep cut it's all taken from
George Lucas's original notes when he
was writing Star Wars so this all
happened before George Lucas wrote that
first Star Wars film the terms he uses
to describe the force in that manuscript
that they used in this episode or the
Ashla in the Bogue on so you get the
idea it's not light in Darkseid like
it's almost like the Jedi over the years
have misinterpreted the force so just
like you see Darth Maul trying to get is
Renuka mine both of the holocrons to the
Sith and the Jedi holocron you see this
coming together of the light in the dark
side of the force that's also kind of
happening with Canaan's character as
he's learning from this Bendu monk but
he's basically telling him you know red
flashing warning science you know once
you go down this path you can't come
back so Kanan is still scarred from
losing his sight like he has these
emotional scars he's trying to make
himself whole again and in order to do
that he's taking a very dangerous path
down the force so Ezra and Kanan kind of
on similar paths but if anybody is gonna
cross the line it's gonna be as Rizzo in
that premiere episode you see him using
some Sith techniques like he uses some
mind control he causes an 80 st to walk
off a cliff so he's way more comfortable
with killing Imperials and is getting a
little bit dark but more deep cuts from
the Star Wars universe they introduce
wedge
Antilles big x-wing fighter pilot so
just expect some more stuff from the
Star Wars universe but the interesting
thing about you know the way they're
treating the force the light side and
the dark side bringing those together
the unifying force which is a very you
concept they're kind of dealing with
that in the main films select Star Wars
Episode 7 supreme leader snoke he's
trying to turn kylo Ren into this super
Jedi by taking a fallen light side Jedi
and using dark side force techniques so
he's trying to combine the light side of
the force the dark side of the force to
create something that's more powerful
than anything could be so just expect
that theme to play out in Episode 8
episode 9 so if there was any confusion
everything that happens on Star Wars
rebels is canon to the film's but just
don't expect the film's to directly
address the characters on the TV show
but it's a lot like the Marvel Universe
where everything is connected but all
the TV people aren't gonna be
high-fiving all the movie people every
single week so let me know 1 how much
did you freak out when you saw the
grand-am or follows coming on in this
season and to what kind of crazy stuff
do you think they're gonna do with the
force by combining light side and dark
side holocrons it's gonna be a lot of
fun so there'll be plenty more Star Wars
this weekend be sure to subscribe to get
all those videos everybody is just like
posting all the coolest stuff now so
there's a whole bunch of cool comic book
stuff that I'm gonna try to get through
this weekend too so they'll be new Game
of Thrones new marvel new DC and new
Star Wars stuff coming while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for my breakdown of the rogue
1 footage from yesterday and you can
click here for my guardians of the
galaxy to preview James gonna just
dropped a couple teasers so thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight